[Music]
a uk doll collector
suspects the presence of a ghost child
after cctv appears to show the doll
movie oh my god was it one of those it's
real i'm just real pierce he said
appears though you know when they put a
dead body inside of the little dolls
uh-huh wait wait you ever seen that [ __ ]
like they had like yeah x-ray and then
one of these dolls had a kid in it for
i don't think this is one of those but
it is pretty brilliant is this whole
[ __ ] one of those dumb ass
[ __ ] yes that left the doll in
front of the open window and when the
wind blows oh my god they say one of
those dumb [ __ ] that just
collects haunted dolls that is what they
do they just collect a bunch of dolls
and then they said this specific doll
got sent to them with no name or like
address and they just received it but
here's the video of the doll it's
because it's a robotic doll it's
annabelle because they wanted a viral
video so they so they they put this is
it like a nest cam where they just put
it on the doll specifically to see if it
moves no i guess it's on their
collection just maybe jessica no one
steals it but yeah here's the video okay
they said it looks like a child is
trying to play with the doll or
something okay
oh my god that's moving um that's a kid
bro
that's it no that's it that's it what
though
[ __ ]
look at that head the head movement's
cool that's cool
dude yeah it gave me a hell of a
goosebumps i've seen them people are so
weird i've seen a whole house that's
covered in dolls like that but the scary
zombie kind oh dude i'd rather open a
door and see just a bunch of you know
what i'm talking about
you know which one oh
they're so [ __ ] up
yeah when i when when the brewery has
like uh these art shows i know you're
talking about yeah
i'm not convinced i feel like i'll be
convinced if it goes like this
and then it goes back like
any kind of movement that's not gravity
yes yeah that's true yeah
[Music]
why you thought it was maybe an
earthquake and it just kind of like yeah
it just looks like there's like a a
gravity thing that just kind of like oh
something happened just like you said
like a window moves or just even a
[ __ ] aftershock that just kind of
like that looks scary dude you don't
like it it looks pretty scary it's the
backstory if i saw that [ __ ] in my house
i'm [ __ ] burning that whole
collection yeah i think it would have a
little bit more of like an interest if
it was just a random couple with a
random doll but these people are like
ghost hunters yeah yeah bro they're doll
collectors bro there's equity to be
gained by the doll being haunted so it's
like well yeah how about this why do
they need to film that [ __ ] corner of
the room exactly
sketch already what's up with that it's
like there's a baby there yeah yeah and
i'm sure that could be manufactured you
know what i mean they could just have a
little string or something who knows
movie magic dude how much do you think
how much do you think they'll buy it i
don't know yeah how much do you think
they'll buy for now that it's haunted oh
man there's gonna be some dude people
are gonna buy this [ __ ] out of this doll
nick dunn you should do dvd commentary
on movies
like i don't know what this is man bro
[ __ ] movie magic
[ __ ] like cgi or whatever first of
all this guy's a [ __ ] idiot he's like
clearly it's a [ __ ] green screen
[ __ ] morons so yeah they think it's
they said it's like the joints are
physically moving like a human are they
though
yeah they said if it was a natural fault
it would have gone to the floor but it
didn't now i stopped halfway she was
positioned defies gravity why is it
recorded like that i don't believe it
anymore i'm like losing faith let's
watch it again dude because it sounds
like they're trying to like convince
themselves and convince us at the same
time right yeah exactly you guys you
guys don't like to be scared
it's like when i'm lying to nicki and
i'm like oh i hope i get away with this
oh [ __ ]
like if i was really trying to make
people believe it i'd like i post it
with something more minimal like well
looks like this happened today exactly
some people post different
oh my god look at that
it is scary-looking but because of the
room and it's just a bunch of dolls on a
shelf yeah why are they filming that and
there's two other [ __ ] dolls i moved
it's like sometimes our dog collection
gets up and runs away we think it's
funny how they make you focus on that
but there might be a whole toy story in
the back like a dancing and [ __ ]
hiding and [ __ ]
but there's no look at this isolation
what they need to do is get a [ __ ]
kitchen knife
put it on the stove where it's red hot
grab that [ __ ] doll shake it 20 times
yeah yeah you gotta you gotta get the
ghost out of it you gotta make the ghost
angry i like that you gotta heat it up
hey
a doll can't move if it's dead but don't
you think we would see like way more of
these types of videos if like it was
way you know more popular people don't
pay attention to nests here's the actual
doll in like regular light that's the
owner
that's a [ __ ] neck all twisted
it's just why are we making these kind
of dolls why does he have a dog
collection and look at the neck the skin
color of the dog it looks like it's dead
yeah who and that's probably on purpose
yeah dude that guy's cranium is [ __ ]
nuts and i say that as a guy with a
cranium you guys can't say that [ __ ]
why can't i say cranium because you
don't have a big [ __ ] head like i do
i have a big head i have a big [ __ ]
bald-ass head so i can say that you
can't see that do you have a big head
steve yeah
that deserves i don't feel like your
head's big when i buy hats i gotta
[ __ ] do all this yeah but your head's
proportionate because you're a big guy
thanks guys thank you you're six seven
yeah you're just you're just all around
big dude thanks careful boys
you're six seven what in six four yeah
yeah huge dick though that's what i
heard that's what i heard although dude
i was just at the doctor's right and it
was funny they were like wow
congratulations they're like pull your
basketball shorts down lower cause it's
hanging out the bottom no this is great
so i've told i told like nikki you know
that i'm six four and a half like for
like [ __ ] years six four and a half
six four and a half six four and a half
and i like to in the half part because
it drives her [ __ ] nuts like she's
like what do you care about the half
part what the what's up with that one
[ __ ]
so i'm at the doctor's office
we're both there just like because we
just moved to nevada and we're just
meeting our doctors the first time like
our physical or whatever you call it the
general
practitioner yeah great
so so we're both getting like measured
on [ __ ] and i step on the thing and they
do my height and they're like
like okay cool six two and my wife and
nick nikki is immediately like wait what
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] thinks he's
six four and a half and she's like me
like going in on me right
and and i'm like yeah i i am six four
i'm like can should we do that again
should we do it again i don't want that
on my right i'm just [ __ ] with my
manhood right now
my wife is here and they did it again
and i'm six to a gam
so then i'm like wait what the [ __ ] is
going on here it's vegas now it's in my
head i'm like wait he's hungry
they could pay him to [ __ ] with you
exactly right so no so so so then we go
home because this is [ __ ] bugging me
right let me go home
and i stand against the wall and nikki
like like does the marking thing and we
feel the ruler yeah
steve's height exactly
we measure it and i'm like six three and
a half on there so my life is a lie it's
all [ __ ] light it's a bunch of
[ __ ] what are we wearing shoes
where'd you get the six four from huh
where'd you get the six four from from
the doctor every time i went i was a kid
and then this time they said six two six
two you shrank that's right did you take
off your shoes yeah that's what probably
happened you think so you think you
always wore your shoes when you're at
the doctor and you have two inch
platforms yeah that's what happens you
guys think i'm not that tall but then i
put on my shoes or when you were younger
you really were like i gotta stand up
super straight maybe you slouch more now
i probably slashed more now because i
had definitely computer chair yeah yeah
you probably had better posture yeah
definitely i think crypto took two
inches off you definitely took two
you're more than not my bank account
how are you anthony uh 512 here let's
stand up next let's go five twelve isn't
that six feet match it up steve steve is
way taller now exactly okay but no shoes
right no shoes that's all for you shoes
too all right but no shoes yeah these
are high tops and [ __ ] shoelaces
for scale one of those things no but you
anthony got to take his shoes
for sale for scale back to back
six two front to back no i i steve's
like six three years yeah do some body
rolls use the body rules just took your
shoes off yes he's like six three six
four but yeah i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on anyway i mean i don't
think i don't think nurses know how to
do their job anymore
he's pretty tall thank you that is very
tall i am pretty tall
for my age and my race the scale did
help with that see
i can't believe you went a whole two
inches down i'm not dude you're a
multi-millionaire now so it doesn't
matter well how tall are you feels fine
5 13.
six feet exactly 5 12 and a half
realistically yeah i wouldn't have told
this story before it became
multi-millionaire it might have been too
insecure yeah but now it's all good baby
it's all good my baby that's true
because it's a million per inch i think
it's fine that's good you lose a million
per inch yeah
we're gucci we're good let's go so yeah
two inches secure on top of everything
else this is what they think uh i like
women who make me feel small oh dude i'm
telling you dude the ball busters is
like how i that's how i receive love and
so i give physically it's easy oh ball
busting like i was with the chick who
didn't bust my balls once and i was over
here in like two days
not kidding it was like because when
they're too into you and like they're
two like they're like it's like almost
like a hero worship thing in a way it
feels weird on you
so yeah they said that the house is
haunted because it's on the property
where it used to be
i guess they said miners used to live
there and these miners
left their kids basically neglected in
the property where a child was burnt to
death
i feel like they're they really want
they want this to happen in their life
to be so that shelf you're looking at
with adults it's a it's a museum yeah
they want to sell it it's a doll museum
it's like a private doll collection
museum
and uh yeah who's the annabelle uh
people on a bookshelf they're like
supernatural chaser people yeah but
they're like based off of real people
right it's like a museum right now yeah
it's really it's a real place yeah you
always got the dumbest families in those
movies they do they go they move into a
house and [ __ ] every [ __ ] door is
opening and closing oh we should stay
here for a week it's because they're
stubborn and cheap yeah because i'd be
like get rid of this [ __ ] man i'll give
a [ __ ] just go [ __ ] airbnb down the
street yeah i am cheap though i would be
like i'd be like we're not moving we
just bought this [ __ ] house we put a
down payment but the doors are clapping
and [ __ ] so what but part of you is like
i can fix it take off the doors can't be
clapping man [ __ ] pictures in the
picture like this you got a smart house
yeah exactly thank you i'm like cool our
doors open and closed on their own yeah
i think that's like a grocery store
i'm gonna
how come they never called the police
what are the police going to do they
don't believe them they're just going to
be they're just going to be training
something they're going to shoot the
[ __ ] doors
oh my god
they shoot the ghost 87 times
but it was around ghosts it was just a
kid
oh no
now it's a ghost can you shoot ghost
kids
can you shoot ghost skins
[Music]
you